yeah hello welcome to this video play
Grand Master SWAT italic virtual net in
a banker gambit is a principal player so
acquainted to it not what I expected
from him I rather thought you will take
it he's not the kind of person who like
monster and likes to get away people get
away with a gambler's also right okay
it's not a bad line for wife I'm playing
them most ambitious set up against this
there are other other lines there's a
different line of thing that sees black
young equalizing but it's not very
interesting this is a bit more a bit
more interesting i believe what is he
doing here and can i not do that for the
should have six that would be would be
nice we can trade the vision now okay he
doesn't need to trade but getting it to
f6 looks attractive 296 oh my god maybe
96 maybe i can take the form and was
completely oblivious to who yeah i can
probably take on c4
and that damn it was quite a scandal
with them okay I'm taking this it just
ok sure this tactic is not not going to
kill me you can argue about the move of
course strategically it might be it
might be dubious but let's just get rid
of this idea ok but c4 is actually
something that i can attack here quite
welcome he goes for this trade and that
that shouldn't be bad don't think this
position should be bad for black Queen
to e5 me activated have a look at them
looks quite decent I don't have a bad
piece or anything that looks like a
long-term problem the d6 pawn slightly
weak
maybe it'll create just normal
normal-looking move not sure if I have a
clear plan what's how to improve let's
say okay after taking the night at 59 th
594 those things could be tricky that's
absolutely true
okay it takes with the Queen ooh PAH
first sense the Queen away from the B
file i think i should have to do that
that's a good idea and then if you want
to do with this f5 stuff 9x5 and I mean
g6 then I can do it natura for it's not
such a terrible thing to happen at the
moment Queen a3 is also something i can
play it doesn't threaten much though
maybe just here preventing age 594
doesn't do much though
[Music]
okay control this clean be to slightly
annoying you there's no particular
threat yeah i think so i can do that
maybe Queen to d2 our night to d2 is
actually interesting putting more
pressure there I can go lightly 2 a.m.
is there an issue with this move
slightly shaklee looking I put some
pressure on c4 I let's do it let's just
be ambitious the blunder it away it's
just a Knicks game so I don't see any
other wanna take in front now see what
does hang and I've got b5 also i wonder
if he can drum up something on the Kings
side that that's may be possible right I
it's very possible a queen she has six
or so that will be probably dangerous
but I have some stuff with Queenie one
as well yeah if he is not easily moving
all the Knights let's say and then
lonely 21 it's adult it's a tough
decision if he plays Quincy too he
basically says okay I'm worse and then
passive covering the pawn and yeah this
is this is not something that he did he
like to do right Air Force maybe the
idea and then second g six or so
[Music]
okay i played this anyway so let's do it
freeing up we have the seaport 9f for
this kind of thing yeah I have some
stuff here I can take on f3 in this
position an interesting try and that's
it was actually good yes there's Queenie
one awesome so I can check now first ok
check here and then take 120 for create
for what kind of you is that that's my
bishop my bishop from a pool bishop ah
my poor bishop I cannot go back some
have to do this i'm lucky i defy hey I
didn't see that before nine morning
didn't see that before hand I can take
him it's extremely extremely lucky take
them what is that wrong decision ok I'll
take cheeky I can check check check and
here that's not easy now fun probably
the sea point is too strong flight
reason is it is too strong interesting
game I i feel i don't know it was
exactly what i feel i really have some
yeah I think after link is a really good
players what I was trying to say so I'm
happy to have one among the fifty
percent [ __ ] now which is good because
usually our place me simply so let's
click team this is an interesting way of
programmers tribe across the d5 pawn
might become a weakness on the other
hand you have less space so I think this
is fairly okay for black so this and
that 96 the definite really a kind of
irritated me but it doesn't work this is
the threat but I can take here so it
dumb it didn't work and this is
something you can certainly lose are you
about yeah it kind of helps right and
all that yeah getting him to take before
and with the point that c4 is also
somewhat weakish jam assistant look very
active might be six-game by the comp
just a tech head home I like to create
and this didn't didn't didn't look bad
you know we should default interesting
move well that's a very interesting book
something like that you kind of sent to
up to h3 and say okay are you really
well positioned now they're very
interesting can p8 was more of them yeah
more of a non-committal decision right
at six takes takes 23 ever this isn't
bad yeah I wonder at which point is
actually turned out to be good for me so
I how many many
engine was now created this was the
moment again when I said either have to
play actively and give up the cohort or
admit his words and he basically
admitted his worth so this was the thing
to make a growing up I was fairly
certain the beekeeper this is so
deserted him if I take and can we can I
can't can't can make a draw with that
another segment this is a perpetual yeah
that was the key moment after this I'm
just getting the upper hand this is this
check check check I can take with the
Queen oh my god and that would have been
much easier I didn't didn't spot that a
queen 84 actually I sought to late hours
hit this in mind later and Queenie for I
was happy that I have Bishop Bishop e7
take care so I didn't plan that Jack
this one 2223 I had a huge engine when
how do you call it I found many of the
energy moves so that did that was was
quite good I think okay thanks for
watching